[Musique]
bienvenue à la une de paris saclay tv
aujourd'hui les étudiants ils subissent
de plein fouet la crise sanitaire des
cours en visio une timide reprise des
cours sur le campus plus de petits
boulots
bref c'est la galère difficile d'avoir
20 ans en 2021
heureusement l'université paris saclay
offre toute une série de dispositifs
humains et financiers pour les
accompagner dans cette épreuve et aussi
ceux et celles qui apprennent sur le
terrain la semaine de la découverte des
métiers vise à donner de nouvelles
perspectives à ceux et celles qui
cherchent un emploi six stagiaires ont
ainsi pu découvrir les métiers de la
construction sur un chantier
c'est une initiative menée par le pea
paris saclay avec les grands groupes du
territoire
autre priorité pour le pea paris saclay
un aménagement durable
une convention de récupération de
chaleur fatale a été signé avec le cnrs
mais qu'est ce donc que la chaleur batal
explication dans quelques minutes
enfin c'est un tout nouveau test il
pourrait révolutionner à terme le
traitement de la maladie d'alzheimer
il est signé d'une start up à jean petit
nous avons rencontré ses fondateurs et
puis notre agenda
c'est à la fin de cette émission bien
sûr
c'était il y a un an un an déjà que la
france était confiné aujourd'hui nous ne
sommes toujours pas sortis de cette
crise sanitaire et la jeune génération
paient le prix fort des cours en visio
ap timide retour je le disais dans les
campus plus petit boulot c'est la galère
pour ces jeunes étudiants pour la
majorité d'entre eux heureusement elles
peuvent compter sur l'université paris
saclay qui propose une série de
dispositifs financiers et humains pour
les accompagner voyez comment avec ce
reportage
l'université paris saclay est très très
concerné par les problématiques
étudiante actuellement avec la crise
sanitaire et depuis le premier
confinement donc nous avons mis en place
toute une série de dispositifs pour
aider les étudiants les aider à distance
les aider à revenir ensuite sur les
campus
c'est une université qui est engagée
aussi dans la lutte contre les
discriminations dans l'égalité des
chances
nous avons mis en place des différents
dispositifs d'être social avec des aides
matérielles pour les étudiants en
difficulté d aide aussi à l'achat
d'ordinateurs portables un
accompagnement pour trouver des
logements un accompagnement aussi des
dispositifs d aide alimentaire
nous sommes si soucieux des étudiants en
situation de handicap qui souffre
particulièrement dans cette circonstance
quoi d'isolement de confinement et qui
va des compensées des situations
psychologiques graves concernant les
aides
social donc là l'université en son sein
donc une commission qui se nomme donc
asus qui est en partenaire qui se fait
en collaboration avec les assistantes
sociales du cros depuis donc le premier
confinement on a doublé le nombre de
commissions à savoir donc deux grandes
commissions par mois 1 qui traite à peu
près 80 à 100 dossiers par commission
pour les aides sociales et des aides
matérielles notamment donc l'aide à la
fin d'un ordinateur portable ou d'une
tablette l'aide à la connexion pour
faire connaître ces différents
dispositifs nous avons mis en place
plusieurs webinaire sur les aides
sociales sur le logement également sur
les violences sexistes et sexuelles car
on sait que pendant ces périodes de
confinement il ya eu une recrudescence
des problématiques de violence à la
maison et donc c'est webinaire ont été
suivis par plus d'une centaine
d'étudiants à chaque fois et nous avons
récemment remis en place ces webinaire
après des études sondage auprès des
étudiants nous avons constaté que le
besoin était plus un besoin de reprise
de confiance en soi qu'un besoins
pédagogiques et nous pensons que donc
c'était plus approprié de commencer par
remettre du lien avec les étudiants pour
qu'ils
j'ai envie de revenir et leur faire
connaître les différents dispositifs
leur faire connaître les campus leur
faire connaître les dispositifs dead est
que dans un deuxième temps
à ce moment là nous mettrons en place le
tutorat pédagogique comment faire
découvrir les métiers de la construction
et bien c'est l'objectif de la semaine
de la découverte des métiers
un dispositif d'insertion sociale à
destination de ceux et celles qui
cherchent un emploi six stagiaires ont
ainsi pu se confronter à la réalité sur
ce chantier celui du futur institut de
recherche et de développement du
laboratoire servier
voilà de quoi faire naître des vocations
rencontres et témoignages de ceux et
celles qui ont participé à cette
expérience nous recevons dans le cadre
de cette semaine de la découverte des
collaborateurs stagiaires sur notre
chantier pour les métiers d'électricité
de plomberie et de chauffage is nos
collaborateurs chef de chantier et
conducteurs de travaux était comme
toujours enchantés de participer à ce
genre d'événement parce que c'est pour
eux l'opportunité de partager leur
passion de faire découvrir leur métier
au sein de au sein du chantier
j'accompagne les opérationnels de l'eau
plate et m
la mise en oeuvre d'une partie de leur
stratégie rse sur la question de
l'insertion
l'idée c'est que les six stagiaires qui
sont actuellement sur la chanter plus
comment ces démissions dès la semaine
prochaine sont différents de poste afin
de la fois de réaliser leur d'heures
d'insertion mais je crois que des
binômes se sont déjà formés ça a bien
marché entre certains donc on a toujours
voilà plaisir de participer à ces
rencontres pour batailler vinci énergie
cette semaine de la découverte des
métiers est aussi l'occasion de tendre
la main vers des personnes qui parfois
était un peu éloigné des métiers de
l'emploi
nous espérons que cette semaine de la
découverte des métiers permettra à ces
stagiaires de s'intégrer durablement
dans les métiers de la construction
chez vinci cette action qui a été mené
juste avant cette semaine sur une
semaine de découverte des métiers du btp
elle a été organisée dans le cadre d'un
dispositif qui est beaucoup plus large
qu'on appelle dispositif d'insertion
sociale qui est intégrée dans notre
politique rse donc une responsabilité
sociétale de l'établissement
l'idée de ça c'est de permettre à des
publics en difficulté soient sociales
soient professionnels d'accéder ou de
retourner au travail via des clauses
d'insertion qu'on s'impose d'abord à
inclure dans nos marchés de travaux mais
également qu'on impose à tous maîtres
d'ouvragé qui intervient sur nos projets
et ces clauses
elle impose quoi elle impose qui est 5 %
du montant total hors taxes des marchés
qu'ils soient traduits en oeuvre
d'insertion je pense que cette semaine a
été correctement enrichissante moi qui
est sans emploi actuellement donc ça
permet de me remettre un peu en scène et
puis de repartir à sur des horreurs qui
me corresponde vraiment bien maintenant
c'est à moi de faire une belle réflexion
et de de le voir ce qui m'intéresse
vraiment cissé grutier si ces traceurs
si c'est autre chose
donc voila mais voilà cette semaine a
été vraiment très bénéfique pour moi
[Musique]
c'est une chaleur fatale une chaleur
dégagée par le plus grand calculateur de
france le supercalculateur gens c'est de
l'iddri c' est une merveille
technologique et il va donc permettre de
chauffer les bâtiments du campus urbain
de paris saclay à terme ce sont 4000
mégawatts qui vont être récupérés soit
l'équivalent de la consommation de 1000
logements neufs par an une convention a
été signée entre le pea paris saclay et
le cnrs avec toujours cette priorité
l'aménagement durable de votre
territoire je suis très heureux d'avoir
pu signer avec monsieur alain schultz
directeur général délégué à la science
du cnrs ce partenariat qui va compléter
la stratégie de le pea et déco
territoire de le pea et qui rentre dans
la logique de développement durable et
de rse que le que le cnrs le même porte
fortement auprès de ces chercheurs et
ses laboratoires
l'idée générale dans cet aménagement du
territoire c'est de développer un
territoire développement durable de
faire attention effectivement à tous les
enjeux d'énergie et sur le sud plateau
que le projet porte et qui accueille la
plupart des du pôle académique a été
retenu l'idée d'avoir depuis longtemps
un réseau des changes de chaud et de
froid qui permettent d'optimiser la
consommation et qui s'appuie sur des
ressources énergétiques renouvelables
alors commencer par la géothermie
puisque c'est le leclerc du système mais
aussi du solaire en électricité
le réseau mais aussi c'est ce
partenariat d'aujourd'hui qui permet de
travailler ce qu'on appelle d'énergie
fatale un récupérer la chaleur fatale du
grand calculateur que le cnrs à
développer sur le territoire et kamitani
sera investi un an qui s'appelle idriss
el idrissi est
un grand calculateur qui est utilisé
pour faire des calculs scientifiques
dans tous les domaines c'est même le
plus puissant en france actuellement et
en particulier il a une dimension sur le
calcul de l'intelligence artificielle et
comme calculateur bien qu'il ait été
conçu pour consommer le moins d'énergie
possible
il chauffe et donc il ya de la chaleur
qui sort des systèmes de refroidissement
et le but de cette convention c'est de
faire en sorte que cette chaleur puisse
être récupérée pour chauffer ou faire de
la climatisation ça dépend de la saison
sur les bâtiments qui sont autour
juste pour donner un ordre de grandeur
c'est ça représente à peu près
l'énergie consommée par mille logements
dans une année très calculateur est très
jeune il a été inauguré il ya à peine un
an et on a réussi à faire en un an une
convention qui va permettre de
réutiliser cette énergie tout ça ça se
place dans une stratégie de réflexion
sur la pratique du métier de chercheur
ne faire en sorte que tout en gardant
notre excellence scientifique on arrive
à diminuer notablement notre empreinte
environnementale et notre empreinte
carbone globale du l'ensemble du plateau
[Musique]
et c'est dans un laboratoire du cnrs que
l'histoire d'un gène qui a commencé
cette start up compte bien révolutionner
le traitement d'alzheimer ou une maladie
dégénérative qui touche près de 50
millions de personnes dans le monde
âgées l'outil a mis au point le premier
diagnostic sanguin qui permet de
détecter alzheimer jusqu'à 20 ans avant
les symptômes un test en devenir mais
qui a déjà donné des résultats là aussi
l'intelligence artificielle les
algorithmes ont permis cette avancée
dans la phase dite silencieuse de la
maladie nous avons rencontré les co
fondateurs de cette start-up gengis un
projet dont le concept a débuté il ya
une dizaine d'années maintenant puisque
en fait la première brique technologique
qui était nécessaire c'est le
développement d'un modèle animal capable
de reproduire de façon fidèle la maladie
d'alzheimer et ça c'est une étape qui a
été réalisée pendant que j'étais
chercheurs académiques aussi vrai de
fontenay-aux-roses la problématique avec
la maladie d'alzheimer c'est que il ya
deux éléments à rectifier si on veut
soigner les patients un jour c'est un
diagnostic et les patients plus tôt donc
il a un stade où le cerveau est encore
suffisamment répond de retraitement pour
pour être soigné et le deuxième problème
c'est que les modèles animaux qu'on
utilisait pour identifier les
modulations sanguine n'était pas
suffisamment proche donne donc la
première étape a consisté à la
développer un modèle animal suffisamment
proche de l'homme la deuxième étape a
été d'identifier sur cet animal les eaux
du lac ution sanguine qu'il est pouvoir
servir de signature de la maladie
alzheimer est la dernière étape a été de
montrer que ce qui était observé chez
l'animal était aussi utilisable chez
l'homme pour diagnostiquer les patients
donc là l'idée a émergé l'idée de créer
une start up et donc j'ai tout de suite
cherché un associé qui finalement l'être
non content mais non scientifique
business purement business
dans ce cadre là j'ai rencontré baptiste
et donc moi j'ai une formation purement
business j'étais le maire de la chaussée
en 2015 et je cherchais un projet dans
lequel un vestiaire et un projet qui
avait du sens nous quand jérôme m'a
parlé de ce projet d'alzheimer j'ai tout
de suite je me suis tout de suite dit
que c'était ce projet là qui fait dans
lequel il fallait que je passe le plus
le plus permis
toute notre approche consiste finalement
à générer de la date à partir des
modulations sanguine qu'on avait près
identifiée chez l'animal est donc à
calibrer des algorithmes mathématiques
et des algorithmes d'intelligence
artificielle pour pouvoir utiliser les
marqueurs sanguins pour diagnostiquer
les patients et ça de façon très très
précoce on a fast trade est
présidentielle voit dans une phase où le
patient ne présente absolument aucun
symptôme de maladie d'alzheimer ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que d'un point de vue
traitement on a fait énormément
d'avancées dans les cinq dernières
années et on espère que d'ici à deux
trois ou quatre ans on va avoir des
médicaments qui ont être efficace pour
ralentir la progression de la maladie
est potentiellement un médicament pour
être mission marché d'ici à six mois aux
etats unis et là il va se poser une
problématique un paradis un paradoxe
parents historique par rapport à la
maladie d'alzheimer
c'est là qu'on aura des traitements mais
on sera dans l'incapacité de pour le
prescrit au plus grand nombre
faute de diagnostic facilement
applicable à une grande population est
donc là le diagnostic et jean thie
pourrait finalement servir de chaînon
manquant entre ces thérapeutiques
efficaces et la possibilité de prescrire
au maximum de gens pour ralentir de
façon massive la progression de la
maladie d'alzheimer
notre agenda à présent beaucoup de
rendez-vous dans les semaines à venir
des rendez vous en ligne bien sûr
pandémie oblige vous êtes entrepreneur
du 78 du 91 vous souhaitez rencontrer
échanger avec d'autres entrepreneurs du
territoire
rendez vous aux innovations shaker le
rendez-vous des entrepreneurs de paris
saclay co-organisée par la french tech
paris saclay et incuballiance invités de
cette édition virtuelle
lara rouyres si olivia start-up
adhérentes à la french tech grand paris
c'est le 25 mars à 11h30 et ensuite vous
pouvez enchaîner avec la ji la journée
entrepreneuriat étudiant qui fête ses 10
ans cette année le 25 mars aussi
rencontré en ligne les jeunes
entrepreneurs de l'université paris
saclay et découvrez leurs projets leurs
réussites plus de 100 projets sont ainsi
présentés rendez vous en ligne
évidemment je le rappelle le 25 mars
c'est à 13h15 en quinze ans déjà que
techno farès le grand rendez vous
incontournable des acteurs de
l'innovation
le pea paris-saclay animera un webinaire
le nouveau lieu au thème de
l'entrepreneuriat et de l'innovation du
cluster paris saclay c'est le 1er avril
et ce n'est pas une blague
comme un air de printemps avec le pari
saclay ce prime cette édition 2021 se
déroulent les 20 et 21 mai en présentiel
et anti j talent
deux journées pour découvrir échanger
rencontrer repérer les talents et les
pépites de demain
l'événement permettra d'interroger la
pertinence d'une communauté d'innovation
comme paris saclay en temps de relance
économique
alors les inscriptions sont ouvertes
vous voyez le lien internet pour
s'inscrire
surtout que chaque année l'évènement
paris saclay spring met en lumière 50
start up du cluster paris saclay
rejoignez cette promotion 2021 les
candidatures c'est jusqu'au 26 mars sur
le petit lien qui s'affiche sur votre
écran
allez un petit rendez vous culturel
quand même il s'est compliqué en ces
temps de pandémie mais on y croit alors
ne ratez pas cet événement culturel et
digital il s'agit de l'exposition à
globo 10 la ville dense une exposition
qui présente une série d'imagés
photographiques un panorama humain et
urbain
mêlant les corps aux architectures c'est
jusqu'au 29 avril
voilà c'est déjà la fin de cet élu
si on merci de votre fidélité merci de
votre attention on se retrouve très vite
pour un nouveau numéro de paris saclay
tv d'ici là prenez soin de vous
[Musique]